no writer is going to get an award for  writing this next introduction here is  the president of the Academy again  Arthur free  I think you're doing a good job I have a  memory thing that's what I mean  the board does not vote in Irving  Thalberg Memorial Award every year when  we do that is given to a creative  producer who has been responsible for a  consistent high quality of motion  picture production - Oscars for Best  Picture and a total of 31 nominations -  such speeches as West Side Story The  Sound of Music and the sand pebbles this  high honor qualifies him this year as  the winner of the Irving Thalberg award  the distinguished director producer mr.  Robert wise  those riders doctors cameramen editors  craftsmen on the stages and the back  lots and distant location sites to the  executives that all who make pictures  possible and after the audience's who  respond let me respond with a sincere  and most grateful thank you